el presidente de la república Guillermo
lazo extendió el estado de sección una
tercera ciudad de Ecuador la provincia
de Santo Domingo de los tsáchilas que
tan solo ayer vivió al menos 10
asentados con coche bomba en esta
provincia también regirá el toque de
queda a partir de las 21 horas hasta las
5 de la mañana los ataques con coche
bombas se han centrado en estaciones de
gasolina donde se han incendiado
vehículos o dejándoles para luego
explotarles al igual que la provincia de
guayas y esmeraldas el Santo Domingo se
han restringido los derechos de reunión
la inviolabilidad del domicilio y la
libertad de asociación en medio de
fuertes operativos de seguridad las
fuerzas armadas y la policía se
mantienen en las calles se Han detenido
al menos 600 personas según El Ejecutivo
involucradas con hechos delictivos pero
la otra parte la han protagonizado los
familiares de los privados de libertad
que le solicitaron medidas de protección
ante la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos porque según indican se han
violado los derechos de sus familiares
la defensoría del pueblo también demanda
al ejecutivo nacional desarrollar las
estrategias necesarias para controlar la
crisis carcelaria pero a pesar del
estado de excepción la violencia no
contenido en las provincias de guayas en
Santo Domingo dentro de los centros
penitenciarios y llevándola hacia las
calles El Ejecutivo nacional continua
movilizando los líderes de bandas
criminales hacia otros centros
carcelarios según el resultado para
bajar el hacinamiento e intentar retomar
así el control de las